ne vous y trompez pas, c'est une
zone de guerre et j'honore les différents, certains
de ces mecs ont été enfermés
ici pendant huit ans, vous les appellerez
des détenus, vous ne les appellerez pas des
prisonniers, les prisonniers sont soumis à la
Convention de Genève. Chinois  n'êtes-vous pas
capable de parler biche mais ne laissez pas ces gars
savoir quoi que ce soit sur vous vous les laissez maintenant
entrer dans votre tête vous l'avez compris
vous voulez un livre aimez-vous ça ici à
Guantanamo Bay oui monsieur ce hyung
ne reculez pas  prends une gorgée du
verre quatre sept sur le détenu personne
ne va nulle part
au moins je ne suis pas seulement les choses peuvent changer
tu n'es pas amical avec lui ils vont
te tester et ils feront mieux tu le
regardes il est complètement sur ce n'est pas
comme  noir sur blanc, comme je l'ai dit,
certains d'entre vous pourraient penser que vous êtes ici
pour les empêcher de partir, vous êtes
ici pour les empêcher, c'était une
violation flagrante de la procédure opérationnelle standard
, vous et moi,
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous êtes venu  ici je ne
veux pas  ed pour faire quelque chose d'important